[music]
lips of other weapons of mass destruction
on our earth no one is developing and the
whole world knows it you know it if you
do something like this against us you
will receive the most severe sanctions response
so if you see that there are people
who want to volunteer
especially not for money to come and
help people living in the Donbass, well,
we need to meet halfway and help
masha the status of even visiting the prince I swing
scolds feeling troubles the theater robert without a
passport
wolters fi I’m afraid kei nagai saved my
favor la played it’s worth you conjuring
to celebrate  to that person protecting the tape of the
site address and led to and the pin code of your
firm of kirkors and your business is it worth it
or not forest fashion women maykop photo
deep we need to paint it for the benefit of you
conversations